all right well my challenge has arrived
hey it's ty so what is this it's a
pickled mudfish
so apparently according to our producer
this smells awful
and apparently it's just as bad if not
worse then surstroemming which is like
pickled uh I think it's like mackerel
something it's that Swedish thing that
old youtubers eat okay
so I'm gonna open up and give it a smell
that Jerry yeah I'm just gonna like I
just saw that man go to heaven smells
like actual light well it I can smell it
from here and smell it like what you
know isn't it oh this looks okay I mean
we have no utensils gonna have to get in
that I think I'm I think I've eaten
though oh my god happy yeah it's like
okay so it's like verudi salted fish
right so it's gonna be super super super
salty I'm just gonna grab like a piece
of it weights to show it on camera show
that piece on camera just don't get on
the microphone like Annie's please how
is it
it sounds like I'm eating do it yes it's
just salted fish right oh my god I know
I'm licking my finger some water it's
getting worse because what what kills
you is the [ __ ] rket us the first few
bites aren't that bad but the more you
chew it the more like the flavors come
out and then the aftertaste just just it
hits you and your breath is gonna stink
for like a [ __ ] oh my god it's
[ __ ] stinks now hey guys should you
should wash it down with the durian I
think that would be a good I think
that'd be a good idea
seeing as you did lose pretty badly yeah
don't smell it maybe a jury oh I don't
think like I've eaten a lot of weird
foods in my life this is easily the
grossest thing I've ever had yeah yeah
smell it over that oh Jesus concentrate
it's like a fighter I think the smells
getting stronger yeah we're all out zone
here like this like a nuclear blast I'm
like fine if I hold my nose because like
I don't like smell the thing but the
moment I get rid I could smell my own
breath it's next week when we do the
podcast you will still be smelling it
yeah I really just hope this doesn't
give me like an illness because we're
like going on old time we're going on a
vacation tomorrow yeah I don't want to
be sick it's gonna [ __ ] stink it's
sorry
it's in the windows of this episode like
Jesus